alors on voit donc les avis sont très
divergents on va dire ce qu'on peut
souhaiter également c'est qu'il ya un
mouvement spontané qui est née sur
internet les poussins qui ne sont pas
finalement affiliés à un quelconque
syndicat est ce que vous même vous ça
vous aurait étonné qu'on se tourne vers
le syndicat mais la personne qui a lancé
les poussins et un manque de la
fédération des auto-entrepreneurs quand
il a lancé son mouvement les poussins il
nous a appelés c'était au mois d'avril
on lui a dit stop on va discuter que
gouvernement et on commence pas on va
essayer de dialoguer
donc ça a démarré tout doucement lorsque
on a vu que on peut pas dialoguer que
les décisions étaient prises bien
qu'elle faisait je crois que c'est
important les décisions annoncées on a
une réforme qui est qui change tous les
domaines tous les deux jours tous les
trois jours le premier ministre john van
hamme pinel dit dément le premier
ministre ensuite il ya moscovici qui dit
non au puis ensuite on la rencontre dit
le d autre chose et puis là vous confiez
2010 il dit encore autre jour vous
verrez jeudi d un de vos collègues hier
on a déjà eu dissolue dix propositions
on va en avoir dix autres avant la fin
bon donc quand on habite là sur le titre
de la cvae on a soutenu la pétition
également la c1 pris son envol donc
effectivement il a eu la bonne idée de
lancer cette pétition mais on l'a
soutenu par nos réseaux en envoyant des
emails à tout le monde aujourd'hui d'en
dépasser les 100 ils ont dépassé
décembre on est à peu près à 100 dès
1000 personnes le fait qu'ils aient des
personnes qui ne soit pas entrepreneur
qui soutiennent ce mouvement
alors écoutez vous venez de donner des
chiffres
si elle et poussins qui se sont mis en
avant on voudrait pas être les dindons
de la farce puisque si on prend par
exemple des auto entrepreneurs dans le
monde alimentaire il ya quand même une
certaine sécurité qu'il faut apporter à
nos consommateurs et sachez que les
règles font que l'état n'a aucune
possibilité de visiter une production
d'un auto-entrepreneur une production
alimentaire d'un auto-entrepreneur donc
c'est quand même un point assez
important et aussi doivent quand même
répondre à à
partir du moment où vous pouvez pas
aller contrôler voir si c'est fait dans
le bon usage tout reste c'est là c'est
le résultat qui compte et voir si les
gens ne sont pas malades une fois avoir
consommé le plat donc alors ça c'est un
premier problème le deuxième problème
ben on l'a vu aussi sur l'autre votre
reportage c'est un petit peu la dérive
frauduleuses qui est donnée à certains
certains en auto entrepreneur et
notamment dans le bâtiment puisque tout
le monde peut s'inscrire en trois clics
auto-entrepreneurs et ça leur donne un
garant vis-à-vis de la loi pour pouvoir
peu vrai et sans avoir peut-être les
capacités alors justement pour pouvoir
dans lequel artisanat il ya une
préquelle à sion au répertoire des
métiers quand même obligatoire et donc
du coup un b sens absolument mais sans
aucune on doit inscrire tout le monde
sans avoir à demander quel que soit un
certificat de capacité à vous demander
comment ils jouent les diplômes non mais
attendez les chambres de métiers sont
sympas elles vont dès 2009 des deux est
en phase d'être intervenir samsa ils
sont très sympas mais je pense que ça
c'est un langage tout fait dès 2009
elles ont crié hier d'être battu elles
ont dit arriver novelli ah bon et dès
2010 novelli a dit tous les
auto-entrepreneurs home activité
principale qui sont des professionnels
artisans ou qu'une qualification vont
aller récente du métier le somme de
bettié l'ont pris le char d'ailleurs de
les inscrire de leur faire des
formations de leur faire payer des
droits d'inscription au bout d'un
certain temps et c'est bon donc on peut
pas avoir le beurre l'argent du beurre
et la crémière bon donc ça ses premiers
points deuxième point encore une fois ça
représente mais je ne le minimise pas
qu'une petite partie et on est d'accord
avec eux pour régler cette petite partie
et mettre ensemble des choses pour mieux
contrôler nous avons écrit que dans le
rapport qui a été fait par
l'administration il y avait 28
propositions on a écrit le 25 avril au
cabinet madame pinel que nous étions
d'accord pour mettre en oeuvre toutes
les propositions qui concerne
l'accompagnement le contrôle des
qualifications les statistiques et ses
feux dont le au lieu de dire ah ben oui
mon contrôle pareil et c'est bon mais
c'est pas parce que madame pinel décrète
qu'on va le faire que ça va se faire
avec quel argent avec quels moyens on va
contrôler des dizaines de milliers
d'autres entrepreneurs donc feu dont le
mettons nous autour de la table et
discutons le mais encore une fois je
voudrais dire quelque chose je trouve
important qu est aidé dans votre
reportage on parle de la création
d'entreprise mais aujourd'hui à 500000
auto entrepreneurs ont créé leur job
leur emploi sinon il très ou au rsa ou à
pôle emploi voilà donc
de l'emploi sabrina que je suis à la
création sachez que l'artisanat créé à
créer pendant entre 2008 et 2012 créer
dix mille emplois par an et il ya une
stagnation depuis 2010 l'artisanat ne
crée plus d'emplois et on a perdu un
client dont il ya la crise mais il ya
néanmoins on a grand père vingt dix
mille emplois par an d'inscription de
création d'entreprise palette
entrepreneurs monsieur moix écoutez j'ai
je suis je me suis m'occupe d'une
entreprise artisanale dans le val de
marne qui a 14 salariés qu'à 20 ans
d'existence que dans la climatisation je
fais je fais de la prévention dans le
cadre d'une mission qui m'est confiée
par un organisme professionnel et bien
en train de coude de coude de couler et
uniquement parce que tu es la crise donc
et je vous dis dans un temps d'existence
bon donc voilà il son inspiration des
métiers et donc faut pas non plus mais
tout la crise la fraude le travail au
noir moi j'ai coutume de dire que les
autres voilà on enlever du travail au
noir à certains artisans du bâtiment qui
le feu dès le samedi avec le camion du
patron qui aujourd'hui le fond en auto
entrepreneur ou de 12 en valeur le fond
hier aussi ce cas là
pour conclure juste en dimensions sur la
réforme qui qui a été annoncé dès hier
ces dix neuf mille euros 47 1500 euros
quelle honte quelle position vous avez
pas répondu
on continue je peux vous dire que vous
savez il ya quelque chose qui est très
fort chez les auto entrepreneurs comme
celle et artisans parce que je pense que
ça peu près très proche où ça c'est que
ça touche tous les territoires toutes
les familles le petit village et je peux
vous dire que ça bouge et ça bouillait
ils vont voir leur profil général et mon
valeurs d'écouté sera donc ça continue
le mouvement continue bien entendu nous
on continue madame fidèles a fait cinq
versions à l'enfant une fillette pour
une 7e daniel vernet ça me convenait
déjà un premier pas puisque on est
toujours en dialogue avec aussi madame
pinel puisque on l'a rencontré les
instances de la pcem1 à la rencontre en
ce moment très fréquemment
absolument
néanmoins bon oui c'est c'est limité
dans le temps c'est bien on est on est
là pour aider les auto-entrepreneurs à
devenir des artisans et ça et il faut il
faut le dire et on veut puisque les
artisans sont des gens kfor qui
transmettent leur savoir il faut que les
autres aux entrepreneurs viennent dans
l'artisanat pour faire la même chose
parce que
nous sommes des artisans et nous voulons
nous pérennisons nodo nos métiers nos
actions et au travers des chambres de
métiers et il faut qu'ils aient les
auto-entrepreneurs fins leur projet
préparent leur projet et après passe
dans l'artisanat quand c'est pérenne
merci pour vos positions très
divergentes suffield artisans monsieur
et je connais bien problématique on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler c'est dans ce
sens que vous allez repartir et permet à
terminer cette émission peut faire toute
la nuit
et bien je vous en prie faites la suite
l'info en plus les infos en plus mes
enfants plus alors tout d'abord le
tribunal de commerce de paris a reçu
lundi les deux offres de reprise
partielle de virgin l'une de
l'enseignent de loisirs culture a
portant sur un magasin et l'autre de
vivarte groupe de prêt-à-porter portant
sur neuf magasins pour obtenir de
meilleures conditions mardi les salariés
de virgin ont commencé à occuper cette
un magasin à paris les champs elysées
grand boulevard barbès mais également
ceux de rouen vignon dunkerque et
strasbourg demande 15 millions au lieu
des 8 proposait hier la direction de
virgin megastore a annoncé la fermeture
de ses 26 magasins officiellement pour
des raisons de sécurité les entrées ont
donc été fermée entre 15 et 15h30 le
virgin de saint quentin en yvelines se
voit donc sa faim entériné et le
tribunal de commerce doit examiner le 17
juin la liquidation de vidy la des
liquidations judiciaires je vais y
arriver de l'enseignent c'est donc la
fin d'une époque une entreprise qui se
ferment on va faire un point sur les
créations d'entreprises dans les mines
au frisbee ou un petit point sur les
créations 1023 entreprises on en parlait
en avril ont été créés dans département
donc selon l' agence pour la création
d'entreprise sur les quatre premiers
mois de l'année on compte ainsi une
baisse de 7% par rapport à l'année
dernière autre info en plus pour
conclure la sncf on n'en parle pas
uniquement en ce moment à cause des
grèves et oui pas uniquement elle fait
aussi parler d'elle sur un tout autre
sujet les web applications pour les
smartphones ou internet transilien lui
stif lens etc aux franciliens point fr
vous pourrez voir l'économie financière
de votre trajet en transports en commun
et votre contribution à la réduction des
émissions de co2 transilien sncf lancera
également le 24 juin une autre
application gratuite tranquille bien le
principe on rentre ses horaires de
trajet et sa ligne et nous apparaît une
rame colorée en vert les voitures où
l'on trouve beaucoup de place assise
orange fréquentation moyenne et rouge
grosse affluence cette application est
actuellement testé par 2400 personnes et
sera disponible sur iphone dans un
premier temps et on termine ma chronique
de l'écho avec la jambe a très
rapidement alors deux dates donc tout
d'abord le site de production guerlain
basée à orphin ouvrira ses portes ce
week end le un événement qui est
organisée dans le cadre des journées
particulières organisé par le groupe
lvmh regardant c'est donc une première
depuis sa création en 1994 le site
produit 35 mille flacons par jour en
somme la totalité la production de
l'enseignant et puis une deuxième date
la journée rse à saint quentin en
yvelines aura lieu mardi prochain martin
hirsch président de l'agencé du service
civique sera présent et lancera cette
journée sur le thème solidarité
entreprises territoires les entreprises
basés localement donneront également des
témoignages comme renault la poste ou la
csq merci clair on retrouve donc la
semaine prochaine nouvelle chronique de
l'écho on s'intéresse à une école à
présent une école européenne de la
sécurité privée qui vient d'ouvrir à
versailles sa particularité 100 % des
élèves sont assurés d'avoir un contrat
en cdi à la fin de leur formation les
explications
ansoumana enfile son nouveau costume
lundi il intègre et la toute nouvelle
école européenne de sécurité privée le s
p basé à versailles cet établissement va
former 13 recrues au métier d'agent de
sécurité la particularité tous sont
assurés d'avoir un cdi à la fin des 400
heures de formation
un dispositif mis en place avec pôle
emploi la paix aux oeufs préparation
opérationnelle à l'emploi sans nouveau
concept ans c'est une première promotion
et je suis ravi d'intégrer un pour cela
la sélection est faite en amont auprès
de demandeurs d'emploi premier critère
la motivation des élèves car leur
secteur d'origine est souvent bien
éloignées des métiers de la sécurité
faysal était magasinier ça fait mine de
riant-parc six ans que je cherche un
travail
en cdi j'ai toujours été en intérim en
cdd dans la même boîte je n'ai jamais
été embauché pour faysal une chance de
retrouver un travail et pour
l'entreprise partenaire quasiment le
seul moyen de recrutement en
ile-de-france wheeler que ton est un
vrai vrai problème paradoxalement on
pourrait croire que la crise nous amène
plus de candidats ce n'est pas le cas il
ya un vrai problème d'image de ce métier
qui donc de fêter facto n'attire pas
forcément une formation pour répondre à
la pénurie d'argent mais aussi pour
mieux connaître ses futurs salariés et
les postes qui conviendrait le mieux à
leur personnalité en attendant la fin du
cursus ce sont surtout les élèves qui
apprennent à connaître leurs futurs
collègues direction la base de loisirs
pour une initiation au catamaran
mercredi il fallait montrer que l'on
était prêt à se mouiller pas facile
quand on est débutant
par équipe de deux ou de trois pour les
repêcher les recrues centre est dévolu
sur l'eau et les seuls qui finissent à
l'eau ce sont les directeurs à partir de
la semaine prochaine les élèves suivront
des cours théoriques liés au monde du
luxe et à la gestion des conflits et
passeront des diplômes de sécurité
incendie et sécurité privée cette
première semaine vise surtout à la
cohésion de groupe sans nous emporte la
coordination eh ben pour une meilleure
entente pour bonne intégration girolles
et dans ce milieu a priori masculin les
femmes aussi se sont déjà intégrés ils
sont
solidaires avec nous ils sont galant
aussi y'a pas de ya pas de gêne le s p
prévoit déjà de nouvelles formations de
ce type avec d'autres employeurs dès
septembre prochain
je vous redonne l'une des informations
du jour le don du sang journée un
mondial demain dans 190 pays la france
est le pays hôte cette année dans les